مقطع عفوي لنقاش يغني اثناء عمله في ضوء
جدران احدى الشقق التقطه بنفسه ثم قرر
نشره على قناته عبر يوتيوب في سبتمبر 20
20 دون اي مونتاج او مؤثرات مقطع لن يشرحه
لك يوتيوب لكن ربما تنصفه الخوارزميات اذا
بحثت عن الاغنيه الاصليه التي كان يدندنها
بكره يا حبيبي لورده الجزائريه بعد نحوي
عامين من نشره يقرر احد المستخدمين انتشال
هذا المقطع من غباره الافتراضي ويعيد
احيائه على فيسبوك لتبدا القصه احمد سالم
المطرب النقاش كما يلقبه الاعلام يستيقظ
ليجد تفاعلا هائلا على المقطع الذي نسي
انه
وما زاد من حيرته تفاعل الفنان رامي جمال
وعده بانه سيشاركه الغناء في ذويته او حتى
يساعده على انتاج البون كامل يترك احمد
ادواته التي يفتخر بها ولا يزعجه لقبه
الفجر الفني المرتبط بها ويركز في مسيرته
الجديده يلتقي بالصحافه وينتقل من برنامج
لاخر ويقيم اول حفل في مسرح سقيه عبد
المنعم الصاوي ويستعد للغناء مع الفنانه
اصاله بحفلها في دار الاوبرا المصريه
وبعد تحضيرات وبروفات جماعه اصاله بالمطرب
الشابي استبعد احمد من الحفل بسبب عراقي
المفاجئه وانقسم الناس حول القرار وتتولى
اطراف عددهم مهمه الدفاع عنه ويكتفي احمد
بعباره بسيطه على حسابه دون ضجيجا ولدجا
الحمد لله وربنا شايل لنا الاحسن